The joe rogan experience.
I have so many memories of just not even playing.
They're just going to Hollywood.
I used to go watch bands.
I used to go watch van Halen play.
I used to go just hang out,
you know,
and um,
that's sort of half the fun of the rainbow is just being there and seeing all
the freaks and all the cool people and all the,
you know,
the people like,
oh,
there's that guy,
there's Lemmy from Motorhead,
there's all these strange characters,
walkers and all these people that had been around Hollywood
forever.
I don't really know why,
you know,
uh,
it's just,
you know,
it's right next to the Roxy.
It's just,
um,
it's just one of those spots.
It's one of those spots are people just get a good vibe there or something.
You know,
strip is just,
the sunsets trip is just one of the all time classic spots in Americana.
I mean,
just really is where the comedy story is.
The viper room is,
it's incredible.
And whiskey,
the history of going back to even like days of the doors.
I mean,
are you,
you know,
just to know that they played the troubadour or even,
uh,
you know,
early days with like Linda Ronstadt,
her backup band was like Don Henley and Glen Fry,
you know,
that was their backup pen and they went off and made the eagles or whatever,
you know?
So,
yeah,
it's,
it's nuts.
It's,
you know,
the,
the history,
it goes way beyond,
um,
the,
the 70s and the 80s,
it's like,
goes back to the 60s and,
you know,
I mean,
you've got the doors,
look at how big that bandwidth,
you know,
they're,
they're the type down like that.
You don't think of them doing regular guy stuff.
Like they're there to me,
you know,
when you're a kid and you think of a band and
you like,
I know they don't drive through Mcdonald's like we do.
It's like they're almost alien or so that,
you know what I mean?
The mystique of that been sort of a road by the Internet.
Like there was a thing the other day were Charlie Sheen was a having a Twitter
beef with his ex wife and it was,
that's ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
But it was the,
that's been that,
that sort of thing.
It's different now.
It's like it is just used to be the one that guy was a big star that they would
be sort of living up on a house and the behind these crazy games,
he know what he doing.
You know?
Now you're on the Internet,
you're literally in two minutes.
People are watching your show a,
you know the show you're playing in France,
they're watching it in La and you just got done with the show like two minutes
ago.
Well,
and then they get to read your Twitter page and see when I was getting a kid,
it would literally be this much of an event.
It would last all day.
I'd go buy like Robin Trowers record,
go to my friends,
you know,
we'd set up everything,
man.
I get to speakers outside of the window and listened to this album over and over
and over.
Now kids download 300 songs in 20 minutes before they go to school or in their
iPod or whatever.
It's just not,
it's not as personal as it used to be.
You know,
like it's more accessible,
it's more accessible.
It's uh,
you know,
I,
as Randy was in Conrad,
the article with,
uh,
David Grill or whatever from,
um,
foo fighters.
Yeah.
If we fight around in,
in Nirvana and he makes so much sense to me because I,
I went through all these things that he's talking about,
which is playing with guys that don't really play that good and we're jamming in
the garage and pissing off of my parents and you know,
and just going through that and improving from there and just getting better,
you know,
whatever.
Instead of people just thrown together with the songs written by somebody else
and all that,
you know,
it just,
the,
some of the human element has been,
that's my only complaint and it's not really a complaint,
it's just,
I,
I just prefer that people play music in not machines.
You know what I mean?
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
Well,
there's also the experience of going to the record store and looking at the
album art and take it home.
And I love that.
There's definitely something missing in my driving 200 miles or
150 miles to do a photo shoot when I'm going to be the size of an ant on,
on,
you know,
microchip.
Yeah.
But or whatever.
But you know,
I,
it's not really complaining.
My whole thing is I just want to get our music to the people the best way I can.
And I,
if you know your way around the Internet,
you can,
you can get that done.
And we just got done up to this big monster cruise and you know,
30 bands on this big ship and we went and played on an island and you know,
it was like a,
it was great,
you know,
so I'm,
I'm not bitter or anything.
I know things are different.
It's a really difficult on major labels,
you know,
because we can go,
what are our next Elma,
your house and your computer.
You know,
that puts a lot of power in the artist's hands though.
And it also puts a lot of power in their ability to promote themselves.
All they need is the Internet now.
Exactly.
And all of those other closed off avenue was like,
we were talking about getting on the Ed Sullivan show was everything to a guy
like Rodney Dangerfield.
He couldn't get on the Ed Sullivan show.
You were fucked today for a comic,
especially,
boy,
you don't need that at all.
I mean,
my friends who have become famous from the Internet,
like Joey Diaz and Ari's fear and Duncan Trussell,
they've only had the internet.
The Internet is all they ever need it.
But all they had a neat,
all they needed was talent and a an an avenue.
In my days I needed a staple gun and the posters and sunset boulevard to get
people to come out.
And then they had to see the poster sided by it.
Like,
hmm,
what comes by?
And they put it ours.
Oh,
say that again.
It goes over,
there's the wars of posters.
It's still awards.
Well,
there's the Internet wars now.
You know,
there's,
there's definitely a lot of that.
There's still a lot of fucking morons out there when it comes to that kind of
stuff.
But,
but uh,
I think it's definitely a better time as far as putting the power in the hands
of the artists and these people that are the normal cabal that we're controlling
the music industry.
They've,
they've lost a lot of their power,
right?
Oh yeah.
And you know,
the difference now is we don't need millions of dollars to,
to record and,
and all that kind of promotion.
And that's why that they're,
the major labels are suffering a bit.
And yeah,
the,
where the power comes in is we're no,
no longer are we just getting our little points,
you know,
when they're taking,
we make $1 million and the record company gets,
you know,
900 and whatever.
And you know,
they throw our crumbs enough crumbs to where we don't like go away.
But you know,
but people don't realize that for most folks they'd done,
they'd have no idea.
Like how bad the deals were at span.
Hailing sale was amazingly bad.
And,
and they even speak about it on the Internet.
You can go on and they're sit together and they were actually interviewing each
other about the old days.
You know,
people think we're the bitching rock stars,
but we are,
we were literally broke there.
They said that their checks per week,
this is during the first album where $88 and 83 cents or something.
Yeah.
And they were selling millions of albums.
Okay,
here's the funny part.
Um,
they got off this tour and,
and the record company says you owe is $2 million.
And he goes,
okay,
let me get this straight.
So if we do 10 tours and sell 20 million records,
we're going to owe you $20 million.
That's insane.
It's just from all the loans and that,
you know,
the first coming out of the gate.
But um,
well it's also just a corrupt system that has too much power.
It's corrupt.
And you know that being the artist when you don't have your own representation
and,
and you know,
you just want to do anything to break out of this club scene.
You know,
you want to be a big ban on big tours and so you,
they take bad deals.
You know,
a lot of,
a lot of bands have done that.
You know,
they've done successful with their album sales,
but their business side of is really horrid.
Yeah.
That's also the difference between a business person and an artist.
Like a lot of artists are impulsive and they're just not that good at things
like that.
They're not that good at business.
And I'm one of them,
you know,
our deal wasn't great either and uh,
but we've kind of made up for that.
We was in our whole career,
but at the beginning it wasn't that great,
but
well,
it sounded,
it always starts off.
Nobody ever says,
oh,
we've got an awesome deal right out of that gate.
And we're very fortunate to have an ethical record right now,
which is you talking about the fucking scoundrels that signed you,
right?
I mean,
that's also,
you think about a music company.
How many people did they sign?
I mean they,
I mean,
they might sign 101 of them might become great white.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of failure involved on their end to prognostication doesn't always
come down.
That's what they call their write offs.
You know,
the write up dance,
but yeah.
Yeah.
But for a band that successful,
the,
the reality behind it.
Did you ever read that piece that Courtney love wrote on the,
um,
the music business?
She wrote a pretty incredible piece about explaining the expenses and how much
it actually costs and what an artist actually gets paid and how much the studio
gets paid.
Right.
And how they go about saying how much things are worth
then read the piece.
But I'm glad she wrote something like that because it was school,
the audience and you know,
yeah,
it's pretty,
that's not their business.
Pretty incredible stuff getting,
yeah.
Well,
there's a little bit of that,
but it's also some of their business
people will understand that,
you know,
we work really hard and we're not just walking around,
a Zillion zillionaires are we good
bummed out when the whole Napster thing came along and people started
downloading MP three s and it just almost immediately sort of took the wind out
of the sails of a records.
MMM.
You know,
I was bummed out even before that a little bit.
But you know,
I know me,
like I were talking about earlier that I'm a fan of music and I like to support
the artist.
I go out and buy their albums.
You know,
I,
I want the artwork,
I want to know who wrote the songs.
I wanted to know where they recorded this album.
I,
you know,
I just think that's part of it.
And it's what makes the world go round in music is to support the artists.
So I go out and buy a Zz top CD and you know,
when somebody comes up and go,
hey man,
I just got you to a new album.
I copied it from my friend.
It's like,
well thanks.
You know,
at least he's going to maybe give me some feedback and if he likes it or not,
or hopefully he'll go see alive,
you know,
go see a live or whatever.
But yeah.
Um,
I dunno man.
Yeah,
it is what,
I'm not going to say that that for it is what it is,
but it is what it is.
I mean,
we were changing.
The world is changing around us.
Technology is forcing us to change and we have to adapt.
But the most important thing is you're still creating,
you're still doing what you love.
You're still doing what he's doing.
And then the commerce aspect of it has to morph and as to morph to accommodate
this new environment that we live in.
But the environment is so beneficial in so many other ways.
It's just,
it just is what it is.
Yeah.
It has to change.
There's no way you're not going to have the world change when something like the
Internet comes along.
So all these other way,
but the,
I think the benefits way outweigh the negatives and am I right?
Yeah,
definitely.
And our fans are loyal to,
I mean we go over to,
you know,
Sweden or you know,
uh,
Switzerland or whatever and they're all there in front of the stage,
you know,
so,
so we,
we are blessed in that way.
I mean,
you know,
no matter what happens in the industry,
our fans have always hung,
you know,
so it's like,
well that's cause you guys appreciate it.
No,
but I'm sure that has a lot to do with it.
We are grateful for our fans and I always tell them that.
And you know,
in the,
in the days when we were playing arenas,
every night is very difficult.
You know,
that the constructed meet and greets,
we can only meet a few and you really can't go out and say,
hey,
you know,
invite 20,000 people backstage j to put for the party.
You know.
But we've really taken advantage of,
of being able to hear their stories.
Man.
I mean,
I'm talking like stories that I don't remember.
you know,
people doing my laundry and it gave me a ride here,
or you know,
they were in this certain place,
or this guy got married to this song,
or you know,
uh,
I got laid because you know,
that your song,
this one,
or,
you know what I mean?
It's just the stories are endless.
And,
and how you personally effected these features?
Yeah.
If our music is involved with people's life on like that,
because I have,
again,
I can relay it because like I was saying earlier,
I literally have visuals when I hear certain songs,
you know,
like I remember where I was,
how old I was,
what I was doing.
You,
you know,
almost like the smell that was in the air practically,
you know?
And so when people come up and have a similar story about music that,
that my band was involved in,
it's like,
you have to feel like that's a pretty,
uh,
tall compliment,
you know,
to,
just being involved with that.
Okay.